let's get to some of your questions amy
trask i'm not familiar with that person
who was the first nfl executive to
openly avowedly happily note that she
that she part is a hint by the way read
pft regularly and to share that everyone
else did too only they refused to admit
they did so yes it was
it was amy trask and it was a long long
time ago and basically she said 90
percent of the league is reading pft and
the other 10 percent is liars so uh
but she was the only one for a while
back in the renegade days of pft that
would actually admit to it so she's been
a loyal friend of the site for a very
long time sheree
and we love amy trash mike if you don't
follow her on twitter she's a good
follow
yeah and uh did a great job with the
raiders for a very long time does a
great job with cbs now i remember when
she first left the raiders i thought
well she'll do tv for a year or two and
end up working for another team i think
the game is better off having the
benefit of her opinions publicly than if
she was exclusively working for one team
at burn unit with the 17th game coming
will seasonal stats be looked at or
recorded differently it would be harder
to compare future seasons with past
seasons hey i can only
relate to our own experience shireen
when they went from 14 to 16 games in 78
nobody ever said boo there was never an
asterisk when eric dickerson set the
single season rushing record nobody said
yeah yeah but you know before it was 14
this 16 you know we need to do per game
that was never an issue it was never a
thing it was never discussed no one ever
cared about it we just we just at a
regular season game and eventually the
records are going to be broken
yeah they will be broken mike and you
look at for instance a thousand yards
receiving or a thousand yards rushing
that's not going to mean as much as it
does now right
five five thousand yards for a
quarterback is going to become more
common so i think you're going to take
all those things into account when you
start talking about hall of fames and
that sort of thing but yeah the records
don't change and it's really weird but
you will see every once in a while
that was the record for a 14-game season
we're gonna have a bunch of those
especially early that was a record for a
16-game season you know he broke the
record in the 17th game or however you
phrase it but we will keep those in mind
at least for the next few years and
here's the thing to keep in mind too
there's never been a 2 000 yard
receiving season
117 yards per game is what you need to
get to 2 000 yards in a 17 game season
and maybe as soon as next year with 17
games for the first time somebody can
get to 2 000. a red zone out because
another franchise tag the best option
for dak prescott i
well look
if if the cowboys don't give him a
long-term deal that he's happy with yeah
it's the best option for him at 37.68
million but i think the cowboys need to
get him signed to a long-term deal and
get that cap number down so they can do
business this year great for him to have
the leverage that comes from 37.68
million horrible for the cowboys to have
37.68 million on the books they got to
get him signed to a long-term deal
before ideally shireen before the window
closes on applying the franchise tag
because if you apply the tag again if
you even apply it you can never tag him
again during his career because then he
gets a 44 raise the next time you would
tag him
yeah absolutely mike and they're going
to try to get this done over the next
two weeks they're going to start talking
they've had some preliminary discussions
mike they've talked for almost two years
they know what the other side wants this
should not be hard the cowboys are going
to have to give in if they want to sign
dak prescott and frankly that's what
they have to do and they have to do it
before march night they have to get this
deal done so they don't have to apply
the tag to dak prescott again that will
kill their cap they've just got to get
this done and they've got to get it done
relatively quickly
there was an item in
espn.com today about labor negotiations
over the years and there was a strange
quote from jerry jones is there another
kind where he talked about owls and
chickens in certain phases of the moon
and whatever the owls and the chickens
were doing when jerry jones coined that
phrase they may need to be doing that
again to get jones to finally admit his
mistake because that's the problem as
they've delayed it's gotten more and
more expensive at some point they just
have to cry uncle i don't think jerry
jones has ever cried uncle shireen
nope he's never been able to do that
never had the feet held to the fire mike
everybody's giving in to jerry jones
including dez bryant at the 11th hour so
they've got to get this done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports